[Music]
and something fishy news sauce submitted
by Ronald McDonald yup trader ass [ __ ]
experts are questioning the story of two
sailors who were reportedly lost at sea
for five months all the things aren't
adding up are they wait wait is this the
two female that leave Hawaii and got
found it yeah I learned about this story
what do you know but I'm gonna let TIFF
tell the story because I'm polite I
don't think you're gonna let her first
quick tell us start before anyone else
in the rustlers do you think even I even
took a breath - you wanna dog what did
you hear just tell me I want to hear
your side okay I heard that they watch
Moana right and then they got super
inspired after they watched Moana and
they said [ __ ] I'm about to travel from
Hawaii to Tahiti or Galapagos or one of
those Islands Tahiti alright and in
there like I'm gonna go and then they're
dumb ass left and in there was dogs and
then stuff like that with them and they
had enough food for like years because
they over-prepare but then something
broke and then they couldn't a legate
and in a Japanese fishing company came
and found them and say you are not tuna
you're not dolphin
this is librarian what we hold are they
because they hunt for tuna and dolphin
this story is crazy how about you tell
the real I don't know what the Moana
Park but that sounds fun I made that one
up to make it sorry I'm the Hollywood
version where I have to add [ __ ] to make
it more like entertaining or maybe that
two sailors were just lesbian there was
gonna add a love story right I think
they might mention it would yeah always
make a love story I can't I don't think
that the last thing I would do was ever
go out into the great deep blue
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that [ __ ] is frightening
as [ __ ] I think it's calming take it
away
alright so these two sailors these two
Jennifer and Tasha and their two dogs
they were stranded at sea for five
months
so back in May they started their trip
and they said that from Hawaii that
party got right so he said they were
saying that there was a storm that
happened that just destroyed like their
GPS satellite phones radios emergency
gear like all this [ __ ] that they had it
just went on the fritz girls suck a
saline shut up damn okay so by the end
of May their boat engine failed and but
they still continued to sail and so they
did have one rescue device that did work
and it's called the emergency position
indicating radio beacon or Everett
you've got the one that goes I don't
know and then like the boats and that
the detecting one we're detecting yeah
so that one it sends an alert signal out
and it sends a location to rescuers
within minutes and it can be activated
either manually or automatically but for
some reason even though it worked this
whole time they never activated it so
that's fishy cuz girls suck at sailing
that's like you keep saying or they're
just out for the adventure fart baby
yeah so it's not sailing that they suck
at it's just directions you use you
don't do you know direction don't say
that about girls man it's it's gotta be
accurate yeah it's the directions it's
the direct it's not sailing any we aid
everyone can say hey hey I know a lot of
guys that's like that direction - okay
yeah and a lot of them are stubborn for
asking directions you and they can't
admit that they're lost yup
ever ever ever know who this is but I
know I'm terrible on I always ask for
directions and that people assume that I
know what I'm doing I always tell them
it's awesome look one of your own is
admitting that they said what I'm Union
I'm unique though I'm like I don't know
anything I don't even know how I got
here but he doesn't try to sail that's
right Jesse does in his [ __ ] his
[ __ ]
everything just goes on the fritz I
wasn't in control of the boat what
baffles me is they had this big device
and they didn't turn it on yeah because
they were saying they were saying that
they didn't they were not in immediate
danger like that they weren't gonna die
anytime soon because they did have
enough water enough food I thought they
had a storm though
yes well the storm is what just blew out
all their electronics except for that
one rescue device right that it was
unlike battery or whatever right and so
there was this uh-huh so even after they
got up literally like there's crazy
[ __ ] rain the boats rocking there's
[ __ ] lightning and she's like do you
think we should [ __ ] press this
emergency bet yeah I know but they're
sailors I think that's accurate I think
it's two white girls and they're not
Hawaiian Hawaiian they're like they just
left from Hawaii so they that was their
destination but it's it's like can you
confirm those it's two white girls
oh it's not one white lady and then the
other one I think Polynesian isn't the
button because you called it third
lesbian lovers and they just wanted a
love and peace adventure back boat
that's the backbone she just wanted to
get some [ __ ] privately at the time of
when they set sail or when they're
saying that there was a storm that there
were no storms near Hawaii around that
time that they're saying so that's
already fishy it was a sexy star
it was raining women juices are they
trying to like create a story get Fame
yeah yeah yeah that's what experts are
like that's why they're questioning who
are these experts because they ended up
getting rescued by the Navy near Japan
like 900 miles southeast of Japan so at
the they were trying to go out to here
they ended up near Japan and the u.s.
maybe saved them and the experts are
just saying like it'd be such a shame
that this is all like a some sort of
publicity stunt to get Fame like they
use actually resources that are needed
for this [ __ ] because they're just like
why would they not call for help yeah
yeah cuz they wanted a movie about them
yep
so this is their their boat this is when
they were getting rescued their sales
sales bucked up too and then this is one
of the ladies this is one of their dog
Oh horklops and this is the other lady
okay she's got some forearms dude she's
strong yeah dude she was finger banging
that girl that [ __ ] destroyed yeah oh
my god
I will show you good leaving it's like
keyboard button gets stuck just got
smashed in it's like that [ __ ] the
[ __ ] is just like indented inside and
you gotta squeeze the outside [ __ ]
finger be no fuck-ups
that's like this like that and you gotta
let me show you a clip of them
explaining why they didn't run out the
room okay I wasn't sure the floral
loading we had the bar floating we had
food and water and we had the ability
for limited navigation I did not feel
that we were in
danger if I'm calling them and I am NOT
an imminent danger that means that their
resources are being used on someone
who's not technically about to die
someone else on the other side of the
planet or in their area could actually
be in imminent danger the word of the
day limited they know they've been
selling for ten years they have always
learned like don't ever call for for
help unless you are in imminent danger
so that's the reason why they didn't
call but then I found it personally kind
of odd because right after they got
rescued they did like a press conference
kind of thing and they were saying that
same lady was saying that she they were
about twenty four hours away from death
what wow they look I don't know I mean
I'm not saying that I know what people
look like when they're starving but it's
pretty healthy pretty healthy they had
like a year supply of food or something
yeah and they were out for five months
dad a lot right yeah they had a lawyer I
don't know exactly how much but they did
have enough food what if they had a
doctor's visit and the doctors were like
Walt you know if you didn't come back
within 24 hours you guys would have been
dead and you're like oh [ __ ] I didn't
know cuz I felt completely fine maybe so
these girls are just saying at that
print press conference that they were
grateful for their service that they
save their lives the prides and smiles
we had when we saw US Navy on the
horizon was pure relief what did they
say to them like we don't need you or
not an imminent danger
oh no it's because the day before they
were spotted by a fishing vessel and so
that's when the Navy ended up getting to
them because the fishing vessel I was
right about the fishing yeah nailed it I
wonder how the dogs do with like [ __ ]
motion sickness dude ostia motion
sickness
thank you that's it yeah that's when
they'll vomit in the back of your car
whatever when they're not used to it
I never had a dog vomit in the back of
my car yeah maybe your own in always
know more than it Ronan Ronan did I have
no idea but even cats have it dogs going
to the bathroom like oh yeah they need
to smell like a patch of grass sometimes
because they're so conditioned to like
poopoo pee pee on the dirt so they're
just like I don't know
yeah I know that's weird
boarded thrown their trash out in the
sea maybe the bulb train huh take a boat
that looks fun yeah but you're also
saying that there were a group of sharks
attacking the boat what I never thought
were attacking the boat never heard of
that
yeah there's one book of stories now I
know cuz it doesn't smell like anything
I will listen when Poseidon came up and
he came your stories getting a little
weird
I saw Ariel so people saw [ __ ]
Medusa's Island so people are accusing
them of being frauds or doing it on
purpose for some other thing I want to
know who these experts are because when
people hide behind the word expert it's
like I want you to come out and say you
are the fraud detective of the sea I
told you one of them make it mm-hmm I
told you one of the experts which is a
meteorologist saying that there was no
storm near the islands I think that's
one expert and I know that like other
sailing experts they're like that's so
weird that they didn't send out the
signal
I believe Sherlock Holmes but these guys
sound kind of weird kind of fishy fishy
indices sounds I don't know I would say
this though I don't really [ __ ] care
just wanted to kick it see same like why
don't you I mean if even I don't know it
just sounded like a lesbian get away
just let them have a lesbian game they
brought their dogs they're gonna [ __ ]
grind on each other that's fine they
don't want to press the door what if
they were like best friends cuz they
didn't hit the button lesbian get away
that's true
[Music]
[Music]